UKRAINIAN AIR FORCE SAYS ABOUT
100 RUSSIAN MISSILES HAVE BEEN
FIRED AT CITIES ACROSS UKRAINE,
HITTING KYIV, KHARKIV, LVIV, AS
WELL AS OTHERS.
OFFICIALS SAY THE COUNTRY IS
BRACING FOR MORE ATTACKS.
AN AIR RAID ALERT CAN BE HEARD
THROUGHOUT UKRAINE.
THE COUNTRY'S FOREIGN MINISTER
SAYS THIS IS MOSCOW'S ANSWER TO
THE ISSUE OF PEACE TALKS.
CNN'S SAM KILEY IS LIVE FOR US
IN ONE OF THE CITIES TARGETED.
NIC ROBERTSON IS IN THE
NEWLY-LIBERATED CITY OF
KHERSON.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BOTH WITH US.
SAM, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
ONE OF THE REGIONS THAT WAS
STRUCK BY THIS BARRAGE OF
MISSILES.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US?
>> LINDA, THE WIDESPREAD
CAMPAIGN ACROSS THIS COUNTRY,
EXCUSE ME, IS SOMETHING CLOSE
TO WHAT WE SAW, EXCUSE ME, BACK
IN OCTOBER.
WHEN THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
COUNTRY WAS HIT VERY, VERY HARD
WITH ATTACKS AGAINST ELECTRICAL
POWER GENERATING AREAS IN
PARTICULAR.
THAT SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN
REPEATED, PARTICULARLY IN
KHARKIV.
IN KYIV THOUGH, THE CAPITAL,
SOME RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS HAVE
BEEN HIT WITH AT LEAST ONE
PERSON REPORTED DEAD THERE.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN REPORTS OF
EXPLOSIONS IN LVIV, IN MY
CAELEB, SO THE FAR NORTH OF THE
COUNTRY TO THE FAR SOUTH, AND
HERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
COUNTRY, WE'VE ALSO BEEN
ATTACKED.
ACCORDING TO THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES, THEY BELIEVE MOST
OF THE MISSILES, WE'VE HEARD
SOME VERY LOUD EXPLOSIONS, WE
ARE NOT SURE WHETHER THAT IS
OUTGOING OR INCOMING.
HERE, THE ATMOSPHERE I HAVE TO
SAY IS ONE OF CONSIDERABLE
DEFIANCE EFFECTIVELY, WITH THE
POPULATION LARGELY IGNORING THE
DEMANDS FROM THEIR AUTHORITIES
THAT THEY TAKE COVER IN
SHELTERS.
BUT THAT ADVICE HAS GONE OUT
FROM THE GOVERNOR IN MYKOLAIV,
RIGHT THROUGH TO THE GOVERNOR
IN KHARKIV, AND ELSEWHERE IN
THE COUNTRY.
AS FAR AS THE AUTHORITIES ARE
CONCERNED, THIS HAS BEEN
PERHAPS THE WORST OR SECOND
WORST SALVO AND ATTEMPT TO
BREAK THE BACK OF THE POWER
GENERATING, THE ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS COUNTRY,
WHICH AS WINTER IS NOW SITTING
IN, OF COURSE AFFECTS NOT ONLY
THE POWER SUPPLY BUT THE WATER
SUPPLY, AND OF COURSE
ULTIMATELY HEATING.
PARTICULARLY IN CITIES LIKE
KHERSON WHERE THEY HAVE ALREADY
BEEN VERY BADLY HAMMERED AND
ARE STRUGGLING TO GET THEIR
POWER SUPPLIES BACK UP IN ANY
WAY AT ALL, LINDA.
>> I WANT TO GO TO OUR NICK
ROBERTSON, WHO'S IN KHERSON,
NEWLY-LIBERATED CITY.
AS SAM WAS SAYING, A CITY
ALREADY DEALING WITH POWER
OUTAGES.
NOW THERE'S BARRAGE OF MISSILE
STRIKES HITTING NOT ONLY
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS BUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU LEARNING
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF STRIKES,
NIC?
>> WELL, 100 IS THE FIGURE
GIVEN BY UKRAINIAN AIR FORCE.
THE IMPACT IS AN INCREASED
NUMBER OF BLACKOUTS.
AN INCREASED CALL BY OFFICIALS
TO PEOPLE TO CONSERVE POWER, TO
USE IT SPARINGLY.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF THE COUNTRY'S INTERNET
IS DOWN AT THE MOMENT.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS ALREADY OVER
THE PAST MONTH OR SO SINCE THAT
10TH OF OCTOBER, BEGINNING OF
83 MISSILE STRIKES ON UKRAINE'S
POWER INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT RUSSIA HAS DONE IS DEGRADE
IT TO A POINT WHERE THEY ARE AT
ABOUT 40% OF THE POWER
GENERATING CAPACITY WAS DOWN
ACCORDING TO THE GOVERNMENT FEW
WEEKS AGO.
THE GOVERNMENT VOWED TO GET IT
BACK UP, AND IT APPEARS THE
RUSSIANS WERE USING THAT IS
POLITICAL LEVERAGE IN ESSENCE
TO SAY, LOOK.
WE HAVE DEGRADED IT TO THIS
POINT.
IF WE JUST PRESS A LITTLE BIT
HARDER, YOU NOW KNOW WHAT WE
CAN TARGET AND WHAT WE CAN DO.
WE CAN MAKE IT MUCH WORSE.
THEY BOUGHT INTO THE SITUATION
WHERE THE COUNTRY WAS HAVING
THESE CONTROLLED BLACKOUTS
WHERE IT WASN'T JUST THE POWER
GENERATING FACILITIES THAT HAD
BEEN HIT, BUT QUITE OFTEN THE
SWITCHING FACILITIES.
THE FACILITIES WHERE THE
INTELLIGENT CONNECTIONS IN THE
NETWORK, IF YOU WILL, THE
INTERSECTIONS OF THE POWER
HIGHWAY THAT DETECT AND MONITOR
HOW MUCH POWER THERE IS IN EACH
REGION.
THEN BALANCING THE SYSTEM SO IT
CAN BE SWITCHED AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
THAT IS WHAT HAS BEEN TAKEN
OUT.
SO IN MANY WAYS, THE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS HAVE DESCRIBED WHAT
THEY ARE DOING AT THE MOMENT AS
TRYING TO SWITCH THE AVAILABLE
POWER THEY HAVE, SORT OF ON THE
BACK ROADS IF YOU WILL, AROUND
THE COUNTRY, ALONG THE SORT OF
ALTERNATE POWER LINES.
RUSSIA HAS BEEN VERY CAREFUL IN
PARTICULAR IN THE WAY THEY HAVE
GONE ABOUT THIS.
SO THE ATTACK TODAY IS AS MUCH
A POLITICAL STATEMENT AS IT IS
A MILITARY, STRATEGIC, POWER
INFRASTRUCTURE STATEMENT AS
WELL.
THAT IS HOW IT WILL BE READ IN
KYIV.
THE REALITY IS THE GOVERNMENT
KNOWS IT'S GOT A VERY LONG WAY
TO GO TO REPAIR THE POWER GRID.
THE DESTRUCTION THE RUSSIANS
BROUGHT DOWN HERE IN KHERSON
TODAY HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS
COMPLETE DESTRUCTION OF POWER,
BECAUSE THEY WERE AT THE POWER
STATION AND BLEW UP THE TWO 250
TON GENERATORS.
THEY SHOT UP THE OTHER
SWITCHING EQUIPMENT.
THIS MEANS KHERSON WILL NOT BE
COMING BACK ONLINE ANYTIME
SOON.
IT'S EFFECTIVELY DESTROYED
ACCORDING TO OFFICIALS.
RUSSIA IS HITTING A WEAK POINT
IN THE COUNTRY'S SYSTEM THAT
KEEPS THE COUNTRY OPERATING,
THAT KEEPS BUSINESSES RUNNING,
THAT KEEPS THE HEATING ON.
IT ALSO HASN'T SO FAR DAMAGED
THE RESOLVE.
IN FACT, THE OPPOSITE.
EVERY TIME THERE'S A BIG
BARRAGE OF STRIKES LIKE THIS,
PEOPLE DIP INTO THEIR POCKETS
HERE AND GIVE MORE MONEY TO THE
MILITARY TO SUPPORT THEM AND TO
FRONTLINE.
>> EVERYONE IN UKRAINE WANTING
AN END TO THIS WAR.
NIC ROBERTSON FOR US IN
KHERSON.
SAM KILEY IN KRYVYI RIH.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BOTH WITH US.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
THE WAR IN UKRAINE HAS CAST A
DARK CLOUD OVER THIS YEAR'S G20
SUMMIT.
MUCH OF THE DISCUSSION HAS BEEN
ON HOW TO END IT.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY SAYS HE HAS THE PATH
TO PEACE IN TEN STEPS.
HE PRESENTED THOSE STEPS
EARLIER IN A TAPED ADDRESS.
STEPS INCLUDE FOOD SECURITY AND
NUCLEAR SAFETY AS WELL AS A
PEACE TREATY WITH RUSSIA.
HE SAYS THE TIME TO END THE WAR
IS NOW.
>> WE WILL NOT ALLOW RUSSIA TO
WAIT IT OUT, BUILD UP ITS
FORCES, AND THEN START A NEW
SERIES OF TERROR AND GLOBAL
DESTABILIZE A SHUNT.
I AM CONVINCED NOW IS THE TIME
WHEN THE RUSSIAN DESTRUCTIVE
WAR MUST AND CAN BE STOPPED.
>> U.S. PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS
TRYING TO GET MEMBER COUNTRIES
TO SPEAK WITH A UNITED VOICE IN
CONDEMNING RUSSIA'S AGGRESSION.
THAT IS OPPOSED TO THE COURT
FRAGMENTED APPROACH.
THE PRESIDENT OF INDONESIA,
WHICH IS HOSTING THE SUMMIT IN
BALI, SAYS A PROLONGED WAR WILL
HAVE IMPLICATIONS FOR YEARS TO
COME.
>> AND THE WAR.
IT WILL BE DIFFICULT FOR THE
WORLD TO MOVE FORWARD.
IF THE WAR DOES NOT END, IT
WILL BE DIFFICULT FOR US TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
FUTURE AND FUTURE GENERATIONS.
>> FOR ITS PART, RUSSIA BLAMES
THE WEST FOR THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
AT THE G20 EARLIER, FOREIGN
MINISTER SERGEI LAVROV DEFENDED
MOSCOW'S ACTIONS.
>> MORE OFTEN THEY TALK ABOUT
UNPROVOKED AGGRESSION.
THE MORE EVERYBODY IS CONVINCED
THAT THIS AGGRESSION WAS
PROVOKED BY THEM.
AND IT IS NOT IN AGGRESSION BUT
IN OPERATION TO DEFEND THE
LEGITIMATE INTERESTS OF RUSSIAN
SECURITY BECAUSE OF THREATS ON
RUSSIAN BORDERS, AND TO DEFEND
THE RUSSIAN POPULATION OF
DONBAS.
>> LAVROV ALSO CLAIMS NATO AND
THE EUROPEAN UNION HAVE BEEN
PARTICIPANTS IN WHAT HE CALLS A
HYBRID WAR IN UKRAINE BY
TRAINING TROOPS AND HELPING
WITH INTELLIGENCE AND
TARGETING.
OUR CHAIN LEE IS STANDING BY AT
THE SUMMIT IN BALI.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US, MJ.
THIS IS DAY ONE OF THIS G20
SUMMIT.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES PRESIDENT
BIDEN HOPE TO GAIN FROM THIS
SUMMIT?
>> YOU KNOW, AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND HIS FELLOW FOREIGN LEADERS
KICKED OFF THE G20 SUMMIT,
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THERE
WASN'T A SINGLE ISSUE THAT
LOOMED LARGER OVER THE SUMMIT
THEN THE ONGOING WAR IN
UKRAINE.
BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
DESTRUCTION WITHIN UKRAINE AS
WELL AS THE GLOBAL ECONOMIC AND
HUMANITARIAN IMPACT THAT THE
WAR HAS HAD THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
I CAN TELL YOU SENIOR U.S.
OFFICIALS HEADING INTO TODAY
HAVE SAID THAT MOST G20 MEMBERS
CONDEMN THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
THERE WAS SORT OF A RECOGNITION
THERE THAT THERE ARE A HANDFUL
OF COUNTRIES, G20 MEMBERS, THAT
HAVE NOT ALWAYS SORT OF FULLY
AND OPENLY CONDEMNED THIS WAR.
WE ARE OF COURSE TALKING ABOUT
COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA, LIKE
INDIA, SAUDI ARABIA, AND EVEN
THE HOST COUNTRY TO SOME EXTENT,
INDONESIA.
SO ALL OF THIS HAS SORT OF BEEN
A COMPLICATING DYNAMIC, BUT
MOST G20 LEADERS AND MEMBER
COUNTRIES DID ULTIMATELY END UP
SIGNING A DECLARATION
CONDEMNING THE WAR.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS WAS SIGNIFICANT
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN GIVEN THAT
THE U.S. IS OVERARCHING GOAL,
COMING TO THE G20 SUMMIT, WAS
REALLY TO SORT OF ELEVATE THE
COLLECTIVE AND GLOBAL VOICE
CONDEMNING THIS ONGOING WAR.